foreign
[Music]
thank you all for the support Subs on
Twitch and YouTube allow me to keep
going and generate the content
so thank you everybody for the support
and tough times the speedrun continues
we're 17.50 on the nose
hopefully we get an interesting game now
before I start the game
I just want to highlight that as we
climb up the ladder
not only do we get more topical openings
we get more main lines but also the post
game analysis is more and more focused
on explaining opening Theory so the
analysis after the game is going to
start getting more Technical and on the
one hand that is a little bit more
boring on the other this is what I
intended to do with this speedrun which
is to allow people to build up an
opening repertoire essentially from
scratch and without even having to watch
supplementary videos specifically
dedicated to opening Theory which also
will eventually exist but that's kind of
the Zen of the speedrun um and I'll try
I try to make the
analysis as entertaining as possible but
there is a technical component to it
because I you really do need to learn a
lot of theory if you want to play
openings while at any level okay with
that said let's start the game just a
moment
awesome we're playing Black hopefully
you can hear me well we're playing Black
against cattle jewel1 1751
and we've already played a Mech I can
see that we've already played him once
and here we go One E3
all right well we faced this move before
this is I think called the vancourey's
opening it's obviously a second or even
Third Rate opening but it's not
necessarily a bad move in and of itself
it's you know it doesn't really
accomplish much now just so the game
doesn't get aborted we're gonna respond
here with Knight F6 if I remember
correctly the previous time that we
faced E3 I think I played D5 but since
my recommendation against 1d4 is the
grunfels we're gonna play a grunfeld or
Kings Indian setup which is very
effective against 1e3 and what you
should know about the movie three is
that it it has very little independent
value and when that expression is used
what that means is the move often just
transposes into one of several other
openings that could be reached via a
more conventional first move so for
example if white plays D4 here that
position is incredibly common it's
called the Kali system but it's just
usually reached via D4 Knight F6 E3 but
you should definitely not consider the
movie 3 a big mistake and try to punish
it at all costs it's you know it's it's
a completely decent move
okay Knight F3 so there are two very
very good setups I would say against
Knight F3 and E3 the first one is the
more Queens Gambit or slav oriented
setup where you play D5 and then either
E6 or C6 if you're a slav player or your
Queen's game a decline player then well
then you should have probably played D5
on move one but you can also definitely
play on a move too but for the purposes
of this speedrun we are grunfeld players
and so we're trying to be consistent and
so the move that we're going to play
here is G6
and the the grunfelder Kings Indian
setup is
essentially very good against any
opening that involves like E3 or C4 or
C3 any opening where White's Pawn is not
on e4 you can basically safely play the
grunfeld setup and that's part of the
reason that I'm recommending it it's I
think a very practical choice because
you don't have to learn separate
openings in separate lines against every
one of White's Sidelines you can play
this against Knight F3 and you can play
it against G3 and C4 uh so it's a it's a
very very practical choice
and we have indeed transposed to the
Kali system McAuley system is I would
say the cousin of the London the only
difference is that the bishop remains
behind the pawn chain in the Kali and
that's mostly why it is a lot less
popular these days than the London but a
couple of decades ago the Kali was an
incredibly popular way uh it was like
the London of the 1960s and 70s it is
what people played if they wanted to
avoid Theory and play something very
solid and generally this bishop is
fianchetto in the Kali it doesn't remain
on C1
and it hasn't been refuted in fact I
played the Kali in several classical
games in the last U.S championship and
and I won a nice game against Jeffrey
Zhang so it definitely still contains a
lot of Venom and it's an underrated
system
named after Edgar collie don't remember
his nationality might have been German
top one of the top players I don't
remember where he lived I know he played
alakyne so probably early 1900s would be
my guess
Bishop D3
okay so this is of course the typical
Square for the bishop in both the Kali
in the London the bishop usually is
developed to E2 in the Kali it is often
developed 2d3 now
again if you're a pure gruenfeld player
then you might be tempted to play D5 and
D5 is a perfectly workable serviceable
move there's nothing wrong with playing
D5 here but because of where white
developed his light skirt Bishop we're
gonna modify our opening strategy a
little bit and we're going to turn this
into a king's Indian setup and most
importantly you don't really have to
know how to play the king's Indian
because white setup is relatively
toothless so it's not like you need to
know King's Indian theory in order to be
able to play D6 here effectively you can
play The King's Indian setup against
certain offbeat openings and still be a
grundfeld player why am I choosing the
king's Indian over the grunfeld well
there is one main reason and that is
because once we play e75 we're going to
be threatening a fork and that may not
seem like a big deal it's just a Tempo
but it's actually very awkward for white
in many cases to have to waste another
Tempo defending against that fork I
think the king's Indian is an excellent
choice against all of these Kali type
setups and that is why we are going to
play D6 you can also Castle here both
moves are fine but we're really just
going to declare that for the purposes
of this game working as Indian players
I had a girl called it was Belgian 1897
into 1932 yeah died very young
unfortunately but already uh introduced
you know left behind a a major opening
Legacy you might be looking at this and
saying well wait a minute white can push
the E Pawn one more time to E4 and
doesn't that essentially move order us
into a perk which we don't play so the
answer is yes sort of but remember that
white is wasting a Tempo playing E3 and
then E4 so white will essentially be
giving us a perk up a Tempo and a perk
in which white develops the bishop to D3
Which is far from White's best setup
against the perk and so E4 is not scary
at all and you can essentially play that
like a king's Indian so castles we
Castle as well
I would say that most King's Indian
plans are divided into two categories
there is sort of bucket one where you
play for C5 and then bucket two where
you play for E5 E5 is the more pure uh
King's Indian approach whereas C5 is
often the choice of uh benoni players
right the benoni being D4 Knight F6 C4
C5 and whether you go for E5 or C5
depends largely often on what positions
you prefer but also on the setup that
white chooses and as I already pointed
out because of the placement of these
minor pieces I think it's more effective
here to play for E5
now we cannot play E5 immediately
because White's got two Defenders on
that square
we need to prepare it and generally we
prepare it either by playing Knight to
C6 which is the natural move or as is
often the case in the king's Indian
Knight B to D7 if you've watched King's
Indian games you will know that the
Knight is often developed specifically
not to C6 but actually to D7
which of these developing moves we will
play depends on again it depends on
White's next move if white plays c2c4
here which I think is pretty likely then
we will avoid Knight C6 because that
walks right into D5 uh pushing the
Knight to an awkward spot
and that's actually why the Knight is
often developed to D7 in order to avoid
D5 at Tempo
so B3 is our opponent's Choice alright
so that
allows us
to circumvent uh the Preparatory move
and these are all things that you would
know if you're a Kings Indian player
what we're about to play is kind of
basic Betty it's a very standard idea
and of course as you should notice B3
opens the long diagonal and that allows
us to tactically play the move E5
immediately without having to prepare it
not that Knight C6 would be a bad move I
mean it's a developing move but E5
already poses the threat of a fork and
confronts white with some specific
problems in the opening what is white
wall with B3 well probably I assume he
wants to fianchetto his Bishop
now tactically this is pretty easy to
understand if white takes twice who can
spot the response there that wins
material for black
and after d e d e Knight takes E5 how
are we going to proceed
so there's a couple of
tricks there that you should uh be aware
of the correct move is Knight F6 to G4
and you need to go specifically to that
square if you go back to D7 then white
takes on D7
and if you take the Rook then The Rook
on f8 is hanging and white emerges up a
pawn so after takes takes takes Knight
G4 we are attacking the Knight on E5
twice
if Knight takes G4 then we take the rook
in the corner and the bishop evacuates
back to G7
we're up in exchange if white plays
d-e-d-e 95 Knight G4 F4
then we will recapture twice on E5 I
know there's a lot of arrows and white
will be left in complete shambles in
regards to uh their Pawn structure I
mean white will also have to play the
move C3 which weakens the bishop that is
a terrible position also possible is to
meet D takes E5 with the immediate
Knight G4 and in many similar types of
positions I'll show you an example you
actually cannot take on E5 for example
if the white Bishop had already been on
B2 then recapturing would have made no
sense because we would lose the pawn so
in that case what you would do is play
Knight F6 to G4 in this in this position
hitting the pawn three different times
and then recapturing it on the next move
alternatively Knight F6 back to D7 is a
possibility here as well but because
white hasn't developed the bishop to B2
just yet we can essentially take a
shortcut and take on E5 straight away
so we're threatening E4 and it's not an
Unstoppable Threat by any means but it's
an annoying threat and it may Force
white to make a positional concession
I'm expecting our opponent to probably
go E4 himself
which happens nice timing
and I wouldn't say that black is better
here maybe black is a little bit better
but you should not expect to be you know
winning out of the opening against uh
against the system as solid as the Kali
you need to be more patient than that
but we've definitely solved our opening
problems the bishop on D3 is kind of
dumb we've got a great share of the
center
and the position is kind of symmetrical
which means that we will need to develop
efficiently and then try to cause
problems for white probably on the king
side so next we have to decide where to
develop the Knight on B8 again there's
Knight D7 there's Knight C6 in this
specific position I don't see a reason
for us to avoid the more natural
developing move it's not like the Knight
on C6 is vulnerable and it's a good idea
to keep the diagonal for the bishop open
so that we can develop it to G4 or E6
subsequently so let's go with the the
natural move and play Knight C6
alternatively you could play Knight B to
D7 and then fianketo the bishop but that
would be a little bit too symmetrical
for my taste then we would be
essentially copying White's development
scheme and that's just too boring for my
uh
for my for my taste so let's play Knight
C6
I wouldn't even say that the Kali is
worse than the London I think they're
comparable and like I said the Kali is a
very underrated system there are some
books on it that came out recently I'll
give you a couple examples
and it definitely has its share of venom
now the thing about the Kali is that you
can't really play it against absolutely
everything I think it's less effective
against the king's Indian setup than it
is against D4 D5 but much like the
London you you can play it basically
against everything but its strength will
vary depending on what black how black
arranges their pieces
Bishop B2
okay so this is where knowledge of
typical King's Indian ideas really
really comes in handy if you're looking
at this for the first time this type of
position what kinds of moves are you
likely to think about well you're
probably going to see Bishop G4
which I don't really like
because white will play H3 and as I
pointed out before when yuffie and
Kettle the bishop you have to remember
that dropping the bishop back to H5 is
no longer a possibility in most cases
because the bishop gets trapped with G4
and obviously the G6 square is occupied
by a pawn
so Queen E7 is tempting but it's a
blunder because of Bishop A3 right
anytime you align your queen and a rook
and your opponent has a bishop of that
color you need to be mindful Queen E7
Bishop A3 and if you try to block it
with Knight before white plays C3 and
picks up the Knight
so similarly Queen E8 allows Bishop A3
and The Rook is simply trapped on f8
rookie 8 is a better possibility but a
little bit toothless
I think we have a better way to defend
the pawn one that also allows us to
start accumulating pieces on the king
side and preparing for an eventual
kingside attack which is not as distant
of a possibility as perhaps some of you
may think
so what move am I hinting at here well
I'm hinting at the move Knight F6
to H5 which we're gonna play
and this serves two purposes first of
all it defends the E5 Pawn opening up
the bishop and second of all the Knight
is obviously heading for F4 which is a
fantastic Square in most openings right
that's why Ben Feingold refers to it as
knife F5 the F4 square is like if you
want to blindly put your knight on a
particular Square in any position F4 is
the square that's likeliest to be good
because it's just on a great attacking
post it's pressuring the bishop it's
pressuring 22 it should be pretty
obvious to you intuitively why the
Knight is well placed on F4
it's also close to the center so if
white kicks the Knight away with G3 not
only have we provoked uh light Square
weaknesses on the king side but we can
deliver a check on H3 or less
adventurously we could drop the Knight
back to E6 where the Knight is very
nicely controlling some key Central
squares
so this maneuver with both colors is one
that you see in a million different
openings Ray Lopez in the Sicilian you
do get Knights on F5
uh but generally they appear on F5
through a different Square it doesn't
you know they take a different route to
get there
but for any opening there's probably
going to be a variation where you know a
knight lands on F4 or F5
yeah also also we're preparing
potentially F7 F5 again a very typical
King's Indian move with the D file being
open F5 loses a lot of its shine because
it's an incredibly weakening move and it
weakens this diagonal and white is
positioned nicely to deliver a nasty
check on C4 and then you can see that
Knight two five Knight F7 becomes a
problem so in the main line Kings Indian
the center is completely closed white
has pawns on D5 and C4 that is why
you're justified in most cases playing
F5 because white doesn't have access to
any critical diagonals here F5 is a lot
less likely but definitely not out of
the question right if we position our
King on h8 then F5 becomes a serious
possibility
our opponent taking taking his time
or her time Knight C3
so that is a normal developing move the
downside is that it blocks the bishop
taking some pressure off of the E5 Pawn
I do not see any reason that we should
refrain from
continuing to carry out our main
maneuver yeah so obviously Knight F4 is
going to be our follow-up we don't need
to take too much time on it
and we're starting to very slowly
gradually put a little bit of pressure
on White's position on the king side on
the in the center
now are we aiming to trade the Knight
for the bishop maybe actually not out of
the question you might say well isn't
the Knight clearly better than the
bishop yes but you have to be
comfortable with the idea of
transforming your advantage right
sometimes you want to give away a good
piece for a bad piece because it allows
you to gather another advantage in this
case like white will probably recapture
with a pawn and then the pawn on D3 is
going to be a backward pawn and we're
already aimed at it with our Queen we
can play night before and start
attacking that pawn
so you shouldn't you know take these
trades in a vacuum and say well my night
is good the bishop is bad so I'm not
going to consider Knight takes D3 right
there are other factors and other
Transformations that occur that can
justify that trade
can't make an omelet without breaking
some eggs and that is one of the key
tenets of positional chess that I think
a lot of people are not comfortable with
it's that they take these principles in
isolation right don't trade good piece
for a bad piece don't weaken a square
but in many complicated positions you
have to violate certain rules and make
certain concessions in order to advance
your your agenda
right dogmatic is a fantastic word to
describe dogmatic is a is a fantastic
word to describe it
92.
and case in point right our opponent is
immediately challenging our Knight so we
have a choice not responding to this is
not an option right if we don't respond
then white will take
and then white will take our Bishop and
we definitely don't want to get rid of
our fiance our King is going to be weak
and our Pawn enough for is going to be
weak that's bad the move Queen F6 might
come to some people's mind
as a way to support the Knight
but I'm not a big fan because after
Knight takes F4 Queen takes F4 that
Queen can be easily tossed back with him
even a move like Bishop C1
so the when the queen operates alone
like that it's not very scary
so there's really only one viable option
which is in fact to take the bishop and
to transform our advantage yes we give
up our active Knight but we gain the
bishop pair
and we force white to weaken this Pawn
structure
yeah and now the position transforms
from you know dynamic to very positional
we're going to start
assembling our pieces in such a way that
we are likely going to put pressure on
the D3 Pawn but without forgetting that
the king side is still an area of the
board that we can operate on as well
so a couple of important points here
night before is extremely tempting
but it runs into Bishop B2 to A3 which
is a move that we have come across
before pinning the Knight it doesn't win
the night we can defend the night with
C5 but allowing that trade is pretty
iffy because the C file opens up and
white can grab it with the rook and I
kind of want to keep our Knight because
the Knight is doing some very important
work it's protecting D4 it's protecting
the pawn and actually after night before
white can simply grab the pawn I didn't
even see that so Knight P4 is totally
out of the question
much better idea is to make a developing
move right we haven't completed our
development so as many of you are
indicating
the most natural and I think the best
moves just to play Bishop G4 and create
the very powerful positional threat of
Bishop takes F3 which will obviously
completely ruin White's Pawn structure
and weaken the king
not so easy to defend against the threat
if the Knight moves back white drops the
D3 Pawn Knight E1 is very passive so
probably White's gonna end up moving the
E2 Knight
in order to protect the other Knight
with a queen
but this Knight doesn't have too many
good prospects either right if Knight C3
then we have Knight D4 if the Knight
moves to G3 then it's completely
restricted by The Pawn on G6 which is a
kind of idea that I've talked about at
length when a pawn and a knight are on
the same file and there's two squares
between them the Knight is often
completely restricted by that pawn
and Aaron nimsovich who is a character
you should be familiar with the author
of my system he kind of famously said
that
um strong players are able to celebrate
they celebrate every little small
advantage and a lot of games are won
through at a high level through the
accumulation of small advantages that
eventually taken together are
transformed into a bigger Advantage this
is kind of what's Happening Here Right
we've we've got the bishop pair we've
got more active pieces uh White has a
very weak Pawn on D3 but our work is
just beginning because white is still
very solid 91.
so Knight T4 would be a bad move because
if Bishop takes D4 and I see no reason
for us to to give away the Knight
especially and and close the Center
closing our access to the D3 Pawn I
think we should make a general improving
move
to uh increase the pressure on D3 what
kinds of moves come to mind well moves
that allow The Rook to move into d8
the queen on d8 is hogging the best real
estate in town and I would much rather
have a rook on d8 than a queen uh Rook
is just more effective at pressuring
this Pawn
so where should we move our Queen well
there's a case to be made for Queen D7
and just stacking the queen of The Rook
there is also a case to be made for
Queen E7 so that after Rook d8 The Rook
is x-raying the White Queen we're also
preventing Bishop A3 with Queen E7
so I think both moves are possible
they're alternatives
let me think about this for a second
this is actually not an easy question
Queen G5 is also interesting trying to
play actively on the king side as well
in fact I really like the look of Queen
G5 it has a little Edge to it
because we're potentially threatening
some Bishop H3 Shenanigans it's it's an
adventurous move but it's not like high
risk or anything the queen can always
drop back to Chief G7
let's go for it
this is kind of a move in my style
Queen H4 yeah also Queen H4 would have
been good but Queen H4 doesn't create as
many concrete threats
right proximity does not equal activity
right just because the queen is closer
to white skin doesn't mean it's better
on H4 the queen wouldn't really be
accomplishing anything specific what I
like about Queen G5 is that we're
controlling some squares in White's
territory we're stopping Queen D2
and we're x-raying the king okay Bishop
C1 great so
we induce this move yes this chases the
queen away but now the D4 square is
potentially ours for the taking where
should we drop our Queen back to
well we can play Queen H5 but that runs
into F3 and then the queen is really
offsides so I don't like Queen H5
I think we should go back to E7 I think
now is the perfect time for us to move
the queen back
and position it in the center
and we forced White's Bishop onto an
inferior spot now the bishop could move
along to E3 from where it would defend
the D4 Square as well but I would argue
that the bishop on B2 is a little bit
better placed because it well it puts
pressure on the E5 Pawn so we're
continuing to squeeze the position and
continually inducing concessions and
eventually we're going to get our
opportunity to cash our advantages in
you just have to be very patient we're
only 14 moves into the game
all right so let's continue
by putting a rook on d8 also interesting
by the way is the immediate F5 but let's
try to play a little bit more
positionally which Rook should we put on
d8 well in order to determine that you
have to ask yourself what is the other
Rook going to be doing
if we play Rook 88 while the other Rook
might potentially be supporting F5 but I
actually like Rook FDA and the reason
why is that later on in the game maybe
even on the next move we will have the
opportunity to run this ape on up the
board which is a very classic positional
idea right using the pawn as a battering
ram in order to soften up your
opponent's position in your opponent's
Pawn structure and this is an idea
you're most familiar with in the context
of an attack right you do this in order
to break apart the King's Pawn cover but
you can also do this on the queen side
you can do this on the other side of the
board and it largely has the same idea
just because there's no King on that
side of the board doesn't mean it's not
an effective plan and I'm sure you've
seen in top level chess this kind of
plan in action right A5 A4 or open the a
file and the side that has more active
pieces generally benefits from direct
contact between the two armies
yeah so clarification F5 here after H3
Bishop H5 G4 would no longer be possible
so no that doesn't blunder the bishop F3
okay so white chases the bishop away but
weakens his King side even more there's
only one reasonable Square for the
bishop H5 blunders into G4 Bishop D7
Bishop c8r needlessly passive Bishop E6
is a no-brainer
and what I'm noticing is that yes the
bishop is kind of biting on granite but
that situation could change if our Pawn
was on A4 right now it would combine
very nicely with the bishop to exert
tremendous pressure on the B3 Pawn
also important is that we are covering
the D5 Square which means that the
Knight on E2 doesn't have as many
prospects otherwise the Knight would
have potentially aimed for D5 now it's
accessed to that square is barred
White's position is terrible
and what's instructive about this is
that everything's defended it's not like
the win is going to happen in two moves
but White's just got no active prospects
no plan and we have such clear ways of
improving our position
so this is where you have to be patient
you have to understand that your
opponent is actually totally miserable
even if you're not seeing exactly how
you're going to win the game
you don't need to see that you need to
you know celebrate the small advantages
okay Queen D2
now there are many good moves in a
position like this a straightforward
plan would be to double Rooks on the D
file nothing wrong with that the the
issue with that to me is that
even after we do that we're not going to
be threatening to take on D3 because of
this Knight which was actually a good
defensive piece I mean that piece is
saving White's life right now I think we
should go ahead and open up another
front and spice things up a little bit
on the queen side with what move well
it's the move that I just mentioned I
think it's a perfect opportunity for us
to play
A5
aiming for A4
oh again Bishop G5 did we just blunder
in exchange no and for several reasons
first of all we can play F6 ain't
nothing wrong with that but more
importantly we have Queen C5 check F6 is
a move that we would like to avoid
because we'd like to keep the bishop on
G7 unobstructed in order to exert
maximum control over the D4 Square
what about night before well night
before I don't love because of A3 right
Knight B4 is the move that we would play
if it directly attacked the D3 Pawn
I think it's a little bit impulsive and
guess what
we can play night before a little bit
and white panics right and this is
always what happens in these types of
games this happens I would say at all
levels under 2000 where people crack
very quickly under pressure and
understandably so because you want to
get active at all costs and so you do
something impulsive or irrational and
you blunt or something now F4 is just a
blunder and not only does it blunder in
exchange it actually blunders a full
Rook because White's Rooks are
disconnected so the 991 is a uh the bane
of White's existence now or or white
loses a piece the game is over
now if the white knight had been on F3
interestingly enough F4 would not be
such a bad move because imagine if white
would be able to recapture the dark
squared Bishop on A1 right then we would
be left without a fan cutter Bishop in
our dark squares would be glaringly weak
this is a very common idea for white in
many openings that involve a king side
fianchetto such as the grunfeld
and it's a blunder
I think our opponent might resign here
yeah total collapse and I wouldn't say
that we're winning here might we'll
check the engine eval my guess is about
minus 1.5
so obviously the computer is able to
survive these types of positions
but you should take the engine eval with
a grain of salt because this is
virtually unplayable for a human
but yeah too passive right our opponent
was too passive from the start
and there we didn't do anything
extraordinary we just improved our piece
placement we induce some weaknesses and
our opponent cracked
yeah and obviously like some people
watching on YouTube might be like well I
don't get 1750s with one Roy who's but
again right you weren't sitting there in
front of the white pieces suffering
under pressure and spending all of your
time trying to find way out ways out of
it right you're fatigued and
all of us can relate to that type of
situation where
passive play and suffering often leads
to a blunder
yeah definitely I would have loved to to
continue putting pressure it's it's sad
that our opponent blunders The Rook here
because it doesn't allow us to continue
the kind of positional squeeze and I
definitely wanted a game like that where
we win purely positionally by squeezing
the life out of our opponent but it is
what it is this is reality
and you know the other thing I'd say our
opponent I think is going to resign here
is that when you watch like a Magnus
game you might be discouraged because
you might see like 70 move game where
Magnus squeezes a small Advantage out of
the end game like he did against me in
the PCL game today remember that at your
level you're likely not gonna have to
pressure somebody for 70 Moves if you
play good positional chess this is a
more likely scenario like a blunder on
move 20 or 30 is a lot likelier than
Perfect Defense because you're not
playing Wesley so Bishop G5
so again we have two choices we have
Queen C5 check and we have F6 both moves
are in a totally sufficient let's play
F6 because it comes with tempo
no not Bishop F6
Bishop F6 blunder is the bishop because
white has two Defenders on that square
and block has only one uh two attackers
one black is only one Defender
Bishop C H4
okay so we're up a rook but that doesn't
mean the factory stops right we still
are doing what we were doing it's just
we're doing it now with an extra Rook
but before we continue on the queen side
I think it's prudent to address the
problem of the bishop because that
Bishop could get stuck on white side of
the board and the last thing we want
right now is to lose that Bishop so
there's like a million good moves here
the Russian Schoolboy approach is just
to drop the bishop back onto a defended
square if you want to win the game
faster the move that I really have my
eyes on is actually Bishop B6 to G4
which is what we're gonna play
I would say that this is not an easy
move
for you know 17 1800 player to come up
with
because it doesn't seem like it does
anything but it actually does a lot it
pressures the E2 Knight and right now
our main goal is just to simplify
but the second thing it does is it
creates the threat of Queen takes E4 how
did I see that well I noticed the X-ray
between the rook and the Queen and
anytime you see that you should spot
ideas like Queen takes C4 the pawn is
essentially pinned
Knight G3
so our opponent contorting himself to
keep all the bases covered but now I'm
looking at the bishop and I'm noticing
that it's trapped it has no way back
so we don't need to do this again we
could like Play Bishop D4 and win
normally but
the one thing you shouldn't assume is
that when you're up a lot of material
you shouldn't take free stuff that's
never the right approach you shouldn't
go out of your way to pick up poisoned
pawns but if there's like a piece Lying
by the side of the road there's no
reason not to take it
yeah the game is overnight F5
we can even play Queen take C4 here that
would be a fancy move
but more utilitarian is just to take on
F5 and take on H4 and we are not worried
in the least about our quote-unquote
King weakness because why there's no
pieces left and we can always talk the
king away on h8
our opponent has defended valiantly But
ultimately this position is totally
hopeless
Queen H6
no threats right this move carries zero
threats do not be afraid by the
appearance again as I said earlier
a lot of people they see a move like
this and they start panicking or
freaking out ask yourself what is the
actual threat does white even have any
mating constructions here the answer is
no G5 is covered G6 is covered Rook H5
does nothing so there's no reason to do
anything drastic here
um which is not to say that you
shouldn't ensure the safety of your king
or play with an abundance of caution you
should and we will and we will by just
tucking the king away into the corner
right just just to make sure that there
are no Shenanigans down the G file
and of course we can then play Rook G8
and turn the attack back on white
we don't give a damn about this pawn it
matters for nothing
there are a thousand ways to win a
position like this I repeat this every
time that I win with like a ton of extra
material don't feel like if you come up
with a move and I don't play it then
your move is wrong right we're up a rook
in a piece there's gonna be like eight
or nine moves that are approximately
equivalent in strength the way that
we're gonna play this is to go after
White's King using the semi-openg file
we're gonna play Rook G8
and we're going to keep an eye out for
moves that simplify like if white plays
Knight F3 which you just did what move
is like an automatic response that
clarifies the position
this is a move that you should just like
see instantly yeah Knight D4 very nice
Knight D4 forcing the trade
and leaving white without minor pieces
yeah Force trades when possible but
don't go out of your way to do that okay
obviously that also blunters The Rook we
can also take the Knight it does not
matter
but if we want to be really sexier if we
want to get ourselves a nice Valentine's
Day date
can anybody spot a move that just ends
the game in style
right earlier I was asked if chess is an
art these types of moves is really what
I live for absolutely unnecessary but
still pretty
noticing that the King on G1 is
vulnerable to Forks
yeah a couple of you have spotted at
Bishop A1 and C3 is really pretty Queen
takes C3 Knight E2 picks up the queen
importantly notice the role that the F6
Pawn plays if the F6 Pawn was not there
then Queen takes C3 would pin the Knight
Knight E2 would be illegal
so do this you know this is
professionals only don't try this at
home
now we take the Rook
we infiltrate with our Queen
and now we double okay white resigns we
would have played rook ae8 and probably
just gone Queen E1 to simplify
oh Jack says what is the point of saying
you should see this move immediately
when you very well might have viewers
that don't so when I say that obviously
I'm addressing players of the level that
we're currently at just to be totally
clear so like if I say you should see
this immediately I'm referring two
players of like the 1700 level
plus if you're a beginner and you hear
that hopefully you know you're motivated
and you're like well I want to see that
immediately and you ask yourself well
why don't I see that quickly and I'm not
trying to like condescend or suggest
that you're you suck like I'm just
trying to to help people
understand what what are the basics and
what what do you need to prioritize in
terms of your board vision
let's take a look this was a pretty
straightforward game so we won't go
crazy with the analysis but just a
couple of important points
so E3
again there's a bunch of moves that you
could play here now E5 I think is
overrated I would not play E5 this is a
reverse French but white is an extra
Tempo so if you want to draw like
obviously like you can play like this
but you know get me out of here this is
this is not what I would recommend for
anybody this is reverse exchange French
and this is just not fun
um also possible is D5 as I pointed out
at the start of the game and white
likely plays D4 transposing into a Kali
system
so we decided to play Allah Allah grun
felt with Knight F6 our opponent
responded with Knight F3 I think
previously we faced a hippo setup with
D3 B3 and G3 uh you can take a look at
that game which is up on YouTube here
white played a little bit more
conventionally
so Knight F3 G6 D4 Bishop G7 this is all
normal Bishop D3 now to my knowledge
Bishop D3 is believe it or not already
an inaccuracy as as I explained because
it puts these minor pieces on Awkward
spots the theoretical move here is
Bishop to E2 this is how Kali players
actually play it and after castles why
did everything write except put the
bishop on D3 after D6 B3 this is the
main line
and as as in the game we can still play
E5 here
and you can dig around online but I
think this position is very popular and
here black has essentially a choice
between keeping the pawn on E5 but the
way I like to play it is Drive the pawn
down to E4 which reaches a sort of a
reverse French position that is very
common in the king's Indian attack
against the French so this structure is
a lot more common with colors reversed
what am I talking about well in the
French white can play the move D3 which
is the King's Indian attack
and the main line here
is C5 Knight C6 Bishop G2
and in this position white typically
plays E5 and supports it with rookie one
and I think I've even had uh this type
of position in the speed run
there's a very famous Bobby Fischer game
that you can take a look at to acquaint
yourself with the typical ideas here
against me of merceron in the Olympiad
in the 60s but I don't want to delve too
deeply because this is like separate
territory so I think we'll probably get
more chances to talk about these
structures later on for the purposes of
this game let's stick with Bishop D3
so we play D6 White Castles black
castles and here if you turn on the
engine you will see that E4 is the
engine recommendation and I agree with
that I think white should play E4 here
even though it's a pretty innocuous
setup it's still essentially a perk and
I think this is the only way for white
to try to justify the placement of the
bishop on D3
so what would we do after after E4 well
let me actually take a look at what
players have done
can you play E5 anyway here yes you can
although it's complicated
so if you play E5 no I don't actually
think you can
because after the trade
there is an important distinction
between this position and the King's
Indian here Knight takes E4 which is the
typical response runs into Knight takes
F7 simple Desperado sack and white picks
up a pun right you have to take and well
white takes on e4 and whites up a pawn
if you compare this to the king's Indian
exchange variation
and this is why it's so important to
look concretely rather than borrowing
ideas blindly from opening to opening
there's going to be small details that
you might miss which make a certain idea
possible in one position here you can
play E5 what's the difference well in
the exchange variation if y grabs on E5
and we take on e4 and white plays Knight
takes F7 common mistake for beginners
who can tell me why this doesn't work
here
black to play and win pause the video if
you're watching on YouTube
so it's not Knight takes C3 because that
gives up The Rook it is Bishop takes you
through because that is a check
eliminating the attacker now you pick up
the Knight and you're up a piece
so in a weird way the fact that the
Knight is not developed actually
benefits white in the context of
of uh this position so here you just
don't have that equivalent move all
right Bishop takes C3 or whatever also
the Knight on e4 is hanging so that's a
that's a difference as well
uh Knight takes F2 does not work
because after Rook takes F2 Rook takes
F7 I think the simplest is just to trade
and then win the game with Bishop takes
G6 picking up the queen
so you should stay away
from E5 but immediately but you there's
no reason to rush with E5 let me look up
what the engine gives here just a moment
I'm gonna check what the main line is in
this position so I don't say anything
false
okay so this position has occurred
a bunch of times
well over a thousand Magnus Carlson had
this against Dimitri callers and a title
Tuesday but what's hilarious is that
most of the time this position occurs
with white to move right because it
comes from a perk and with white to move
usually white plays C3 with black to
move there's significantly less position
less instances of this occurring and the
engine actually proposes the move C5
which makes a lot of sense here in order
to pressure the D4 Pawn getting almost a
good version of a sicilian dragon
if white takes on C5 then we take back
and we're doing great we get our night
out Etc if white pushes then of course
we play this benoni style with E6
and when I use that term benoni style
what exactly do I mean well the modern
benoni goes D4 Knight F6
C4 now C5 D5 and E6 this is the main
the entrance point to the benoni
so this is a very common idea in King's
Indian positions as well
the two openings are very closely
related and the bishop is usually fianca
the minoni as well
so after C5 D5 we play E6
and I think the position is about equal
if uh White takes on E6
then I would probably take with the
bishop just to keep your pieces
developed then the typical plan here is
to eradicate the backward Pawn on D6
with Knight C6 followed by D5
essentially white cannot prevent you
from playing D5 black is very
comfortable here
now white should probably go C4 which is
the more principled move
but even here it's like a great version
of a modern benoni
and here I like the simple rookie eight
or maybe he takes D5 first
but I like rookie eight because that's a
bit of a clever move
preparing to take on D5 and preparing to
put pressure on e4
and after Knight C3
we play e takes D5
and if white plays CD then you take the
opportunity to get rid of your light
squared Bishop Bishop G4 takes F3 and
then the Knight can go out to E5 you can
dig around here a little bit on your own
but the engine gives equality here I
actually would prefer black because just
black has more Dynamic plans in this
position
if white plays e takes D5 then I don't
think anything changes I think you still
play Bishop G4
you eliminate the Knight
and then you drag your knight over to
the center Knight B to d795 with a very
comfortable position for black
possible continuations the takeaway is
that E4 I think should be met with C5
E4 should be met with C5 and I would
highly advise you if you're like a
little bit unsure about some of these
moves to set this up on on chess.com and
take 5-10 minutes and analyze this on
your own
uh but this is not common enough to
Warrant like a 30-minute analysis
session so when the game white plays B3
allowing us to push E5 straight away the
position is still equal but I already
think white needs to be careful
so once again after Dede Knight takes E5
runs into Knight G4
attacking the Knight twice and after
Knight takes G4 Bishop takes A1 a very
important detail
C3 is a scary move because it traps the
bishop but it weakens the bishop on D3
and allows Bishop takes G4 black wins
the piece I had to see this when playing
E5 this is important
so I don't think 95 works the engine
confirms it of course white can play
Down In exchange and white has a pawn
for the exchange the game is not over
like objectively black is only slightly
better but this is not you know
challenging
and this means that the bishop can
evacuate back to G7
so for that reason I think E4 was
correct
we played Knight C6
and the question now is where did white
start going wrong Bishop B2 is obviously
a reasonable move
and after Knight H5 I already think that
white needs to be very accurate to avoid
slipping into a bad position
believe it or not and I just confirmed
this with the engine Knight C3 is
already
kind of inaccurate but white is already
worse in this position maybe this was
the last chance to equalize
and I think the same move should have
been played both in this position and in
this position
white should have essentially aimed to
immediately discharge as many pieces as
possible because the knights coming in
the pressure is building white needs to
try to trade Queens here so who can spot
a a very like
I mean it's a move that's probably on
your radar but it might not seem like
anything special and yet I think it's
very important for white to play this
move
so you're almost there Bishop C4 or
Bishop B5 the reason I think Bishop C4
is better is because after Bishop E5
black and play Knight D4 and this bishop
is just sort of very it's actually very
awkward and queen G5 will hit the bishop
I think the bishop is just safer on C4
but it's the same idea you're just
trying to trade Queens
and the issue is that if black tries to
evade the queen trade you're walking
into Bishop A3 again if you play Queen
F6 well then you're pinning yourself and
Knight c395 comes with Tempo so probably
we would have played Bishop G4 trying to
trade on our own terms but I think this
end game is holdable I mean I think that
black might be a tiny bit better here
but white remains very solid Knight bd2
we would have played Knight F4 the
Knight is very good even in the end game
the game continues the engine gives G3
here chasing the Knight away obviously
when the Queens are off the board this
is a move that you can play a lot more
comfortably because the light squares
are not as important black doesn't have
the Firepower to attack
but after Knight E6 we go over to D4 and
it's still an unpleasant position
it's still an unpleasant position for
for white much easier to play for black
but that definitely would have been the
way for white to stay alive
here once again after Knight F4 Bishop
C4 I think is very important although
already in this position we have the
option of going Knight to D4
and this appeals to me a lot more with
the Knight on F4
John Mickel asks what if G3 after Knight
H5 well if G3 we would definitely play
Bishop G4 hitting the now exposed Knight
on F3 and this gets really nasty and
probably white has to go here
but now we can refrain from the queen
trade with a move like Queen C8 and
White's just so weak on the light
squares and this could like do
deteriorate very quickly Bishop H3 and
even Knight F4 is a typical type of move
here
and obviously if white takes white gets
checkmated so in most middle games when
you play the move G3 and you don't have
a bishop on G2 it's just dreadfully
dreadfully weak
okay so our opponent played Knight C3
and allowed this trade and after Bishop
G4 the situation is already critical for
why 91 is a good move
Queen G5 I think is a good move by by us
H3 there's there's Bishop takes H3
uh so Bishop C1 back to E7 we bring our
Rook into the game and all of our
subsequent moves were incredibly natural
F3 Bishop B6 and I evaluated this
position correctly it's minus one or so
according to the engine
but as I explained practically it's much
harder to play than that that doesn't
tell the whole story
um the correct move for white here would
have been Rook B1 who can explain
the idea of Rook B1 why
Rook B1 and it doesn't solve White's
problems but it keeps white in the game
take this thing out of A4 very nice type
2 prophylaxis you don't prevent A4 you
can't prevent A4 if you play A4 yourself
you blunder the pawn but you take the
sting out of it because now I4 meets
with B4 and white is okay white keeps
the queen side intact so here black
should be patient the engine recommends
now playing Knight B4 which I really
like after A3 just go back to C6
inducing a huge weakness on A3 and white
is just in a dreadful State here
so we we have a lot of options we can
play a five also good doubling Rooks so
here we would have continued massaging
and squeezing the advantage but I mean
this is almost done even Queen B4 is a
good move
and in the event of the trade this is a
fork on two Pawns
so just like a million options here and
this is very easy to play we have a
couple of questions first question
Value Point one asks he didn't fully
explain why G3 is so bad it seems like
white isn't busted concretely I don't
get it okay so to be clear
this is I assume G3 move 10. I'm not
suggesting that white is losing here in
fact I'm not even suggesting that it's
like that bad what I'm saying is that
white creates long-term weaknesses and
these weaknesses can haunt white for the
rest of the game
and even though you might not see the
win in the next five moves that win
could come 15 moves down the line so you
should divide advantages into two
categories in your mind static and
dynamic static advantages are
essentially permanent they're likely to
last for most if not all of the game
this is an example of a static Advantage
now can you devise a scenario where
white solves the problem of these
squares yes you can if the Queens get
traded these squares are no longer that
significant but most likely they're
gonna haunt white for a long time what's
an example of a dynamic Advantage well
an example would be a development
Advantage something that is very likely
to evaporate in the next couple of moves
unless you act on it so with development
advantage or an initiative where you're
calling the shots that's that's an
example of a dynamic advantage
um you want to try to avoid as a general
rule giving your opponent static
advantages because those advantages pile
up and that's what causes your position
to ultimately collapse
okay that's a lot of I know that's a lot
of you know babbling but I just want to
lay out this concept and then we will
expand on it as we raise our rating
because this is going to get a lot more
important so second question what makes
the pawn on D3 weak well the definition
of a weak Pawn is a pawn that cannot be
protected by any other pawns now that
should be taken with a grain of salt
because you could look at this and say
well wait a second all three of these
ponds cannot be defended by their
neighbors but they're not really weak
right because they can't be attacked and
they're protected by other pieces the
d-pawn is genuinely a weakness because a
it can't be protected by any other pawns
it's a backward Pawn B the square in
front of it is controlled very nicely by
black C this Pawn is on an open file
which makes it very easy to attack and
for those reasons and it's a center Pawn
right A Center Pawn being weak is a much
bigger deal than an a pawn being weak
because even if you lose an a pawn it's
often not the end of the game
and there is no light squared Bishop to
defend the pawn so these factors make
the pawn on D3 a huge weakness
so
that is essentially
the ideas yeah Queen G5 was not
mandatory we could have just played
Queen E7 don't freak out that you didn't
spot this move the idea was literally
just to like intimidate our opponent and
and get him to to bring the bishop back
okay we've got a couple more questions
spiked punch man asks can't you just
push the pun and trade Central pawns if
you're worried about losing it well not
really right it white can't play D4 it's
just not possible because here we take
on F3 and we play e takes D4
if white plays it on the next move again
it's not clearly not possible because
we're pinning the Knight
yeah so
this is also you should notice a
similarity with the iqp structure
isolated Queen Pawn structures
the way to evaluate them is often to
understand whether who controls the
square in front of the isolated Queen
Pawn if it's the side with that pawn
then the the weakness often becomes the
strength in fact our previous Speed Run
game I might remind you featured exactly
that kind of scenario where we have a
pawn it's isolated but we push the queen
away and we're able to push that pawn
forward and then that pawn actually
becomes uh you know the bane of Black's
existence because it it just tosses
black spaces around so so that's the
concept of blockading right that's why
it's so important to control the square
in front of a weak Pawn so that you can
properly attack it it's harder to shoot
at a moving Target where's the blunder
well our opponent didn't make a blunder
until F4 right F4 is a blunder but the
position was already in Dire Straits it
was a series of small positional errors
and finally
I'm just checking to see if there are
any other mistakes or any other
questions
yeah I think we'll stop it here last
question from Bethel gooski is there
positions where it would make sense to
play Bishop G4 H3 Bishop H5 G4 Knight
takes G4 yeah so last topic I pointed
out that in such positions when you have
a fianchetto you want to avoid dropping
the bishop back in response to H3
because after G4 the bishop is trapped
and it's trapped because the pawn on G6
blocks its Escape
so that
for any rule that I share like literally
anything that I say an exception can be
found and a situation can be found
I don't think I'm gonna find anything
but let me see if I can
Finagle a little Searcher just give me a
moment it's it's running the search
yeah I think I'll take a rain check on
this I'll see if I can run a search uh
on my own time because you know people
watching this on YouTube
I value your time as well so I will try
to find an example of this in
preparation for the next video
we're gonna pause here folks
uh but the the upshot is that for
anything I say there are exceptions and
you should not be dogmatic right every
position should be considered concretely
hopefully you enjoyed this positional
squeeze it was a simple game
I might be back late tonight if I'm not
sleepy but most likely I will see you
tomorrow I'll do Arena Kings in Russian
um Arena Kings and Russian as usual
that's uh noon tomorrow
and on that note folks I want to thank
everybody
for watching this was a more technical
game but hopefully you enjoyed and found
it instructive
thank you everyone who subscribes on
YouTube I will raid Benjamin Feingold I
will be commentating the protest league
so I will see you on commentary tomorrow
with uh Tanya sachdev thank you all and
uh thanks for hanging out enjoy
[Music]